great salt lake also expected to reach  its lowest point in modern history this  year the entire state of utah  experiencing drought more than 90  percent considered extreme  utah is the second driest state in the  country but has some of the highest  public water consumption  the governor of utah spencer cox has  declared a state of emergency  and called on the people and citizens of  utah to reduce their water use  and also to pray for rain the question  is  are state leaders willing to accept that  this is not a short-term  drought but that this is long-term  climate change  utah of course feeds the colorado river  and less water in the state means  trouble downstream impacting some  40 million people in seven states